florida ha amanecido con largas filas de
ciudadanos siquiera la fuerte lluvia los
desánimo se trata de personas que
decidieron votar anticipadamente a las
elecciones presidenciales del 3 de
noviembre
esta es una lección histórica es una
lección muy importante porque es momento
de acabar con la división la corrupción
el odio y con respecto a las políticas
de la actual administración creo que han
sido realmente dañinas creo que la gente
debería votar por el partido que crea
que se centre más en las libertades
personales que en las leyes y las reglas
y cosas como estas creo que la gente
debería votar por la libertad de elegir
mucho florida es uno de los territorios
más codiciados porque aporta 29 votos
electorales además se trata de un estado
pendular lo que significa que no tiene
tendencia definida republicana o
demócrata
justamente la fórmula vicepresidencial
de joe biden se encuentra en florida
tratando de seducir a los indecisos en
este estado con gran presencia de
latinos y claver edad
oculto lo que sabía y si miramos donde
estamos estamos en una de cuatro crisis
que están ocurriendo al mismo tiempo en
el móvil en todas vemos el fracaso más
grande de cualquier administración
presidencial en la historia de eeuu
presionan the history of america por su
parte desde arizona el presidente camps
cargo una vez más contra baiden y restó
importancia a la pandemia
pandemia están cansados de la pandemia
no yo estoy cansado
miren bailen es un tonto no tiene idea
quienes apoyan a sus partidos son
radicales maniáticos izquierdistas la
modalidad de voto anticipado estará
disponible hasta el 1º de noviembre se
estima además que alrededor de 2
millones de personas ya han enviado su
voto por correo en florida una cifra
histórica en este decisivo estado